hi I'm Cristin George and I head up
product at TuneIn we have 40 million
monthly active users from all over the
world and TuneIn brings you the world of
live radio to your smart phone so we're
here today to talk about the Android
product and why we're so excited about
our fastest growing platform over the
last two years we've been working on
increasing our overall retention of our
Android product in our first version of
our app we focused on UI elements that
we thought would communicate to users
how to move from screen to screen or
navigate between tabs and use a mini
player so we had our own way of doing
this and it really was this big bar
across the screen and it said swipe here
and we thought that you know this UI
element was going to be extremely
successful and what we found is people
just weren't seeing it so we we moved
over to Google UI element that really is
being used in places like the Play Store
and so at first we didn't think that
this UI element was as prominent and
what we found was when we released it
and tested it on our listeners we found
that it was actually much more
successful than the feature that we had
in place and as a result people were
discovering new and a new great content
that they wanted to listen to so it
ended up moving our our most important
engagement metric which was listening
hours and then as a result people were
finding really great content that they
wanted to listen to on our platform and
they were finding more reasons to come
back and listen to tune in what we found
was by implementing fragments google is
helping us handle all these different
device sizes and resolutions so that we
were creating a really great user
experience on different platforms and so
I'm gonna show off a little bit about
fragments if I come in here you can see
that there are three different fragments
on the browsing side of this screen so
the first is here
the second is here and then the third is
as you choose a particular genre of
music to consume there's another
fragment over here on the side and so
you'll see this with our little mini
player and this fragment moves from the
side of the screen during a tablet UI to
the bottom of the screen during a phone
UI and what we did is we invested once
and then Google is helping us through
this process conformed to all the
different types of screen sizes that
they have we decided to make a very
content first screen so a user can come
in here and they can say these are all
my favorites as far as John res and then
we can show them the world of live
content as it happens so this is our
very content rich experience that's made
for tablets I always shipping a new app
every two and a half to three months so
what that gives us the ability to do is
lean into the new features that Google
puts it out into their releases so when
an example of this is rich notifications
and you'll see that we made it really
easy for people to favorite stations and
songs that they like stop and play and
then also discover new content with our
jump button so you'll see that we have a
full rich notification and our users as
a result feel like we're constantly
improving our app and making them feel
like we're paying attention them and
that we're always building new things so
I'm looking forward to continuing to
improve our product always reaching for
higher attention and really appreciate
your time so thanks for listening